E aí
[Música]
Ei me diz uma coisa qual foi a última
vez que você parou tudo que você tava
fazendo porque você sentiu sede e foi
tomar água ou então você vai que ela
vontade de ir no banheiro e foi na hora
que veio à vontade se ele vai sensação
de trabalhar trabalhar trabalhar fazer
tudo aquilo que precisa fazer mas senti
assim dentro de você e você não saiu do
lugar eu quero dizer porque é porque a
gente tá sempre vivendo lá na frente e
não agora eu quero te contar o quanto é
importante a gente entender que é o
agora que vai nos mostrar qual é a nossa
necessidade eu sei que a gente entendeu
que a vida tem que ser feita de desejo
quando a gente conquistar aquela casa
que a gente quer o carro novo ou é
daqueles milhões na conta Isso é ótimo
mas eu agora eu agora que fala de
necessidade e eu quero te mostrar o
quanto é importante
entender Qual é o seu agora eu e mais o
agora ela se estraga natural e eu posso
te provar na ancestralidade africana
nossos ancestrais primordiais tem uma
frase incrível que fala que nós não
somos a extensão da natureza nós somos a
própria natureza e eu quero que você
bote reparo isso aqui quando eu falo de
extensão muita gente entende que esteja
só é uma continuidade mas outras pessoas
entende extensão como algo fora meio
anexo sabe a gente a um distanciamento
um afastamento e não é isso quando eu
falo da gente se extensão é sobre a
gente ser ser um inteiro ser o todo e eu
preciso que você olhe para isso porque
quando a gente está na ideia de ser
extensão de algo ou de uma ideia ou até
mesmo da própria natureza é como se a
gente ainda não tivesse acionado dentro
da gente a responsabilidade do todo a
possibilidade de inteira a
responsabilidade de quem a gente
realmente é e eu quero te ensinar uma
coisa ano passado você sim como eu
passou pela pandemia Mas eu ainda passei
por mais uma coisa eu passei pelo
falecimento da minha mãe duas coisas que
tira o chão de qualquer pessoa então
vamos pensar aqui todo aquele olhar que
a gente tem de futuro quando algo
acontece no agora pode fazer grandes
mudanças e essa mudança aqui que eu
quero te ensinar não nasci assim não viu
Foi um aprendizado às vezes eu
aprendizado na morte às do aprendizado
de finais de ciclo porque a natureza tem
um ciclo muito bonito de vida de morte
de vida e foi assim que eu fui
aprendendo na alta observação mas também
nesse próprio ciclo dentro da minha
própria casa eu quero te ensinar uma
coisa que a natureza que é a ancestral
que tá aqui muito antes da e me ensinou
três coisinhas a primeira coisa entenda
de uma vez por todas a natureza é
cíclica não existe primavera sem passar
pelo inverno e também não existe verão
aquela colheita maravilhosa que a gente
quer sem ter o plantio e o cuidado
continua a natureza é cíclica e Nós
também somos mas você só consegue viver
um ciclo quando você tá apoiado no agora
naquilo que é e não naquilo que vai ser
porque tudo muda o tempo todo a segunda
coisa que a natureza nos ensina
lindamente é ser amiga do tempo e muita
gente detesta do tempo né a Deus eu acho
que a gente tá o tempo todo nessa briga
com o tempo como se ele fosse um inimigo
que nos tirasse tudo os arrancasse tudo
e deixar se a gente sem nada mas não é
bem assim a natureza nos ensina que é no
plantio e no Cuidado
de olhar para Terra todo dia tirar
aquilo que precisa colocar aquilo ser
meio que princesa que faz com que tudo
cresça amadureça e que a gente tem uma
grande colheita só o tempo nos dá
processo só o tempo marca nossa jornada
só que a jornada também começa no agora
e não eu olhando ai para quando eu tiver
aquela colheita eu preciso que você olhe
para agora para terra que você pisa e se
pergunte qual é a semente que eu tenho
nas mãos e a terceira coisa incrível que
o tempo nos ensina que a natureza nos
traz de bandeja é não se comparar você
já viu alguma árvore parada no meio da
Avenida olhando sim para outra árvore e
falando Nossa como ela é mais bonita do
que eu folhas mais bonitas que flores
mais bonitas uma árvore não se compara
com a outra porque quem se compara não
cresce e a gente precisa aprender isso é
sobre a minha vulnerabilidade a sua
vulnerabilidade as suas jornadas o seu
agora o meu agora então quando a gente
começa a entender a grandiosidade do que
pode ser vivido em um agora essa visão
de quando eu chegar lá quando eu tiver
isso quando eu tiver aquilo ou quando eu
for tal coisa Cai totalmente por terra e
a gente passa a ser uma coisa só agora
Olha aqui para mim quero te fazer mais
uma pergunta
e quando a gente encontra o que é
natural né gente porque a gente entende
que ela agora eu quero que você olhe
para uma única coisa senão a extensão se
você é fiel agora se nada te afasta do
outro porque vocês têm as mesmas
necessidades e é a mesma energia
quem é você quando você está inteiro na
agora senão a mais afastamento quem é
você no agora e é isso que eu quero que
você sinta isso aqui que eu tô sentindo
que quando a gente para de olhar para lá
de buscar o que tá lá e é quando eu olho
para o que tá aqui que eu consigo ter
presença
relacionamento e consigo pensar Até
mesmo futuro é
uma forma melhor maior e que todo mundo
esteja junto então pensando que o agora
ele é ancestral porque ele é natural e
que a gente já sabe viver todos os
nossos ciclos a gente ia entendeu que
não agora que a gente planta que não
agora que a gente se relaciona que não
agora que a gente faz essa costura
humana eu quero falar um pouquinho de
humanidade ou agora também é feito por
nós puramente se humanos
Independente de tamanho cor de raça de
Credo o futuro que a gente quer começa
não agora que a gente cria então eu vou
te dar uma dica a dica que a mãe minha
mãe me deu antes de fazer a passagem
dela de uma forma ancestral e natural O
que é aquilo que eu faço agora é o que
eu vivo agora que vai reverberar e
construir um futuro e não eu não quero
construir um futuro melhor só para minha
filha porque eu não quero morrer agora
eu quero construir um futuro melhor para
mim e eu só consigo fazer isso Se eu
olhar para o agora então vai lá pede
perdão para que cê tem que pedir se
perdoa também pelas coisas que você já
fez e tá tudo bem Vá tomar aquele
sorvete que você ama tomar porque amanhã
né a gente já sabe é no agora então
presta bastante atenção
tudo só existe no agora porque o agora é
a única coisa que a gente tem então vai
viver se ela agora é
[Música]
E aí